[Music]
can i play the smith world well that's
if i have the white pieces we'll play a
10 minute game though i don't really
have the energy for a
for a 15 minute game
and then maybe we'll have a political
discussion so i can properly end my
career
all right
maximilian 0104 okay i'm going to play
something very tactical yeah we're going
to play a sicilian
okay f4 so we face this move probably oh
three or four times in the speed run and
those of you who've been you know long
time clients should know that the move
here is the immediate d75 and that is
the that is why people don't recommend
f4 that's why if you if you're a grand
prix attack player you want to start
with knight c3 now after e takes d5 you
don't take with the queen and again if
you've watched the previous speedrun
games you will know that the proper
continuation here is knight g8 to f6
you're trying to take the pawn
essentially on your own terms now you
might say like well wait a minute
white has just defended the pawn
did we make a mistake no we didn't
and it helps to know the theory here
essentially the point is that the d4
square is now significantly weakened so
what we do is we
adopt the gambit mode we basically play
a gamut we play e6 we force the trade
and then we have
massive compensation
for the pawn and this is a very
well-known line this is a line that if
you're a sicilian player you should
absolutely know this line
and i think i had a speedrun game many
many months ago even over a year ago
where i explained
why black has such serious compensation
but the the elevator pitch is that we
have massive control over the center we
have control over the d4 square white
has a very weak pawn on f4 that's
sticking out like a sore thumb white's
got a very bad bishop on f1 which is
just biting on granite and white's king
doesn't have any clear safe haven
because this f4 pawn is out in the open
and castling kingside doesn't solve all
of black's problems so what should we do
how should we develop in this position
well a3 is really playing with fire
white is not developing his pieces so
i would kind of try to go for the kill
and try to develop as actively as
possible what does that mean what move
signifies that we want to develop a
tempo bishop d6 yeah let's get this
bishop out attack that pawn and i have
this idea of piling up on the pawn why
don't we just attack that pawn and try
to force
more weaknesses in white's position
because white's position is already so
flimsy that if we force more weaknesses
in white's position he might simply not
survive so let's play queen c7 okay
bishop b2 our opponent is totally
ignoring the threats
in this case i'm gonna grab that pawn
absolutely let's take it
and you might say well wouldn't it have
been a better idea to develop our pieces
instead well yes but i also like taking
free pawns so we also open up this
diagonal which could create big problems
for white along that diagonal so what
should we do now well we should
definitely castle we should definitely
castle which way should we castle you
could make a case for either way if you
want to play a little bit safer you
could castle kingside but if you want to
play more adventurously and that's the
mood that i'm in right now
you definitely want to castle king said
this is where the party is at why am i
inclined to castle king's side well
first of all we're x-raying the queen
which is a good thing we're the rook on
d8 is already in the game right
that creates potentially the threat of
bishop takes c4 which i know a lot of
you see but mainly it's the fact that
we're also
reinforcing our control over the d4
square which is
you know as long as we have control over
that square we're good we're chilling
and now i think we can move in for the
kill
now i think we can move in for the kill
now a lot of you are probably thinking
let's go knight d4 but it's not we don't
need to rush with that move we only want
to play knight d4 if white's knight is
gone from f3
with a move that i really like is not
knight d4 but knight g4 creating threats
against white's king bishop takes h2 is
now a big threat and the knight is
potentially heading for e3 this i mean
storm clouds are starting to gather
around white's king and there's a very
very cool line that i'm hoping he goes
for
the line starts with bishop takes f4 so
i'm hoping that he takes the bishop and
then goes queen d2 now white is in big
trouble here white is in huge trouble
it's not totally winning yet but i mean
if white doesn't respond properly to
this then the game will be over very
quickly and all of these problems stem
from the fact that this d4 square is a
huge hole there's a huge huge hole on
that square which means that the bishop
is terrible which means that white's
pieces are very cramped
and our play here is very
straightforward and easy no white is in
trouble here for sure
how should white respond well i don't
really know i think white is in serious
role i think white should take the
bishop here
because that to me seems like the only
only move otherwise we
well we'll at least will take on h2 with
check right so white should at least
take the bishop and then maybe play some
sort of other move queen c3 is not the
way now we can pile up with decisive
threats we can take on h2 right we can
take on h2 and we'll be up upon but i
think we have a much better move here's
how i would think about it
what you should notice is that if the
knight on f3 were to be gone then we
would have the possibility of
checkmating him on h2 well the queen
can't jump over the bishop but what we
can do is move the bishop off of this
diagonal with check
and then slide the queen into h2 so
there's a couple of moving parts here
the first puzzle piece is that we need
to get rid of the knight once we get rid
of the knight we'll be able to play the
move bishop f4 to e3 check forcing him
to either take or go king h1 or whatever
it doesn't matter because queen takes h2
is going to be checkmate so in what
order do we want to do things well step
one is to distract the knight and we
have just the way to do that literally
all i've been talking about is how great
the d4 square is well we finally have a
good use for it we can put the knight on
d4 but the use for it is tactical not
positional we're not trying to use the
square and establish an outpost there
we're literally just trying to distract
the knight
bishop e3 check and it's checkmate in
two moves
if rook f2 then we still take on h2 and
the go queen h1 checkmate
and that's how you dismantle
this line
that's how you dismantle this line
and we're 1900. 14 moves well i mean
black white played terribly to be fair
white played very very poorly
so that's our second game i think in
this line where people play c4 and just
get destroyed
in the first game i think something
pretty similar happened so knight f3 was
fine a3 was a very strange move i i
don't know why people play like this
white's just not developing pieces and
neglecting
the problems in this position so we
decided to go bishop d6 and attack the
pawn on f4
then we decided to pile up on f4 and
queen c2 or bishop b2 was a huge mistake
i mean giving up this pawn after white
gives up this pawn all hell breaks loose
a better idea probably would have been
to go g3 the the problem with the move
g3 is that creates even more weaknesses
on the king side one way that we could
try to exploit that
is to play like h5 very quickly just go
h5 and h4 and open up the king side
completely and just try to go for the
kill so i i think this would have still
been quite bad for white but
at least it's a little bit more
double-edged why can play bishop g2 i
was honestly planning to do something
like long castle and if white short
castles i would even consider h4 here
probably not totally sound you can
understand how good this can be
when played properly black's just got
total domination over the center
in any case
bishop e2 gives up the pawn
then we castle then we go knight g4 and
already it's very very bad the one line
that i wanted to show
in the event of bishop takes f4 queen
takes f4 white can try the move queen d2
white can try to force the queen trade
and black has a very very pretty move
here that i think essentially just wins
the game who can spot this move yeah so
you asked the sam shanklin question what
happens if i do it anyway and that
yields the move knight d4
because if queen takes queen then we
take on e2 classic idea for king the
queen and the king and then we win the
queen with an extra piece
and i think white has no moves here
because you're threatening knight takes
f3 and queen takes h2 nice little move
for sure so
anyways in the game of course everything
was very straightforward and i can show
you a gazillion examples of this idea
being applied in over-the-board play
another example of where pattern
recognition pays off a hundred folds
because i saw this idea really without
even thinking about it what was my major
attempt but that's a good way to get
canceled just the fact that i'm a
history major
the fact that i dared
to major in history
what do professional chess players
normally major in ah well hess is a
history major
i don't think there's there's one thing
necessarily i think it's all across the
board psychology math
i honestly think that the way the chess
world handles fischer
is a great representation of the fact
that chess players manage to remain very
rational
and level-headed i think it's a very
good demonstration of how
cases like that should be treated but
unfortunately i don't think that
nuanced treatment has bled over into
society
similar vibes to coding well that's what
i thought when i took cs classes but
then i realized to me at least and maybe
i don't know computer science well
enough chess and cs had very very little
in common like i was not benefiting at
all for my chess skills
while doing coding
well i think karjakin is getting the
same response i i think that nobody's
saying he's not a great player
i mean nobody's attacking his play you
know people are
keeping the discussion strictly to what
he was saying
yeah i think ding ding has a better
chance objectively of making it to the
world championship so i'm very very
actually very excited to see him in the
candidates i think it's great that he
got a chance
well it's interesting because my friend
and i are are thinking of doing a
chess podcast at some point
so we had a we had like an hour-long
discussion of the karjakin case
he's a lawyer uh he's also a fide master
so
he's a very very close friend of mine
so we spent about an hour
discussing the kuryakyn case
and looking at the actual legal
basis for it
and what the fide decision actually
looked like and what the ban was
actually based on and whether it was
you know as much as
you hate him and that's the hard thing
in these cases like i don't know of a
single person who doesn't react with
deep disgust to like what he said but
the question of course is like
but has he violated any laws or like has
he violated the fide code of ethics and
we came to the conclusion that yes like
he did
and
it's it's a complicated case actually
but
not that he's gonna find anybody arguing
on his behalf and
not that he should but it's still an
interesting
it's really a good exercise in forcing
yourself to think objective like someone
who says really disgusting
you know you hate him
and you just like
you know
you can't look at him without being
disgusted but you still have to
be objective and the law has to be
applied
the rule i guess the law is the wrong
word because we're talking about fide
fide
laws here you still have to have to be
objective so we'll talk about it all
right guys i'm hitting the sack
officially hitting the sack now so
i'll see y'all
later
thanks everybody see you guys see you
guys later bye
[Music]